dans dix jours les étagères seront
remplis de produits du terroir la
poussière aura disparu et hugo roux 23
ans diplômé de l'école du vin à paris
pourra partager sa passion et présenté
150 à 200 références de vins aux morts
passe bien la halle avantage d'avoir un
bar et de pouvoir être au contact de ma
clientèle tous les jours c'est de
pouvoir discuter avec les clients les
conseiller sur des vins pas forcément
que français car vous verrez qu'on aura
une gamme assez étranger et sur des vins
étrangers des spiritueux de tout le
monde et on va pouvoir vraiment la
rechercher le conseil client et à
pouvoir aiguiller le client au maximum
associé avec son père le jeune homme
proposera également à la dégustation des
spiritueux et des planches de fromages
et de charcuteries installé dans les
locaux de l'ancienne librairie fermé il
ya un an la nouvelle cave à vin a pour
objectif aussi de redonner vie au
quartier
un espace dédié à la presse est ainsi
conservée pour répondre aux attentes de
la population locale l'objectif il est
simple c'est de dire aux personnes qui
viennent prendre leur presse de pouvoir
venir partager un moment est de pouvoir
se retrouver autour d'un verre de vin ou
une planche arrêté et pas que d'aller
acheter son journal
situé en plein coeur du centre-ville de
maurepas le coin du sommelier ouvrira
ses portes le 14 septembre prochain pour
une inauguration avec modération